If you're lucky, summer gives you time to breathe. Maybe go on vacation, slow down. You finally have a chance to get to that long list of things you've been putting off. Books to read, exercise, spending some time on yourself. The episode you're about to hear is part of our summer series about rebooting and reimagining our lives. We're calling it U2.0. This week we bring your conversation from the fall of 2016. It explores the idea that the chaos of your regular life
might have some secret benefits. If you're a parent, you've probably told your kids a thousand times, your room is a mess clean it up. We hear the same message in other contexts, managers at companies around the world tell their employees to get organized. Here in the United States, we elect presidents to go clean up Washington. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. My guest today has a radical idea. In many cases, he says,
it's disorder rather than order, that's our friend. Tim Hartford is the author of Messy, the power of disorder to transform our lives. He joined us recently for a live taping, just blocks from the White House, at NPR's Weekend in Washington. It's an annual event that brings together public radio fans and supporters.
Tim Hartford, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. I want to begin by playing you a piece of music come about? What's the story? It's beautiful, isn't it? Two of my children were born to that. It was played by Keith Jarrett, great jazz pianist in 1975 in Cologne, and if you had been there two or three hours before the concert, you would not have expected things to go well. Keith Jarrett had just Mae'n gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch yw'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r recorded the concert because they want a documentary evidence of what a musical catastrophe sounds like So they could play it to future promoters to tell them to do a good job and get a proper piano But in fact, it's a masterpiece It's Keith Jarrett's most popular work. In fact, it's the best-selling jazz album in history solo jazz album in history and the best-selling piano album in history is the Column Concert. And the surprising thing is that all the adjustments that Jarrett had
to make to cope with this bad piano made the music better. So we avoided the harsh upper registers, he stuck to the middle of the keyboard, that makes it sound very soothing. But he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet, so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass to try to get some resonance. And he also just stood up and pounded down on the keys. So you can hear him moaning in frustration during the concert. He's hating it, but it is amazing. And that combination of the peacefulness and the dynamism makes this electrifying piece of music.
So he did not expect that a bad piano would produce a great concert, but in fact it did. And the argument of my book is very often we're faced with the unplayable piano and actually we produce something great out of it. You have a number of examples besides Keet Gerrit about how disruptions and inconveniences and surprises can sometimes have paradoxically good effects on us, even though we all try to avoid those disruptions. You talk about commuters, for example, who suddenly have to find a new way to work, or scientists who are working on so many projects that they are discombobulated because they don't know what they're working on.
In many of these cases, you find that disorder and confusion could actually be helpful. Yeah, so in the case of commuters, there was a transport strike in London a couple of years ago. Shut down, not all, but most of the London underground stations a'r transport strike yn lwmg i'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n g ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn y years ago. One of the things I want to do in this conversation is try and tease apart when messiness can be our friend and when it can be our enemy. There's a reason many of us try and avoid messiness. It's because messiness causes delays, it causes disruptions, you're ending up, you end up being late for some things. And I'm wondering as I read some of the examples in your book, whether
it was the case that messiness helps people who actually have a base of preparation. So in other words, Keith Jarrett, he's a professional musician, he's very gifted, he's practiced and he's learned the rules of how to play a proper piano for years and years and years. You place me before that piano, and what you're going to hear is not genius, what you're going to hear is just a mess. And the reason Keith Jarrett could adapt was because he had the base of knowing the rules to now say I can throw out the rule book and create something brilliant.
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right, Chan-Kar. Is it okay, can I open a big bag of complexity science on you? Absolutely. Okay, so basically, if you are trying to solve a very complex problem, we have various algorithms that try to solve this. And we'll come to the question of skill in a second. a'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r gwybod, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymdwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch y ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymw yn ymwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn So for all the children who are listening to this podcast, I want to make clear that you're not saying that every time your parent tells you to clean up the room, you should just say, Tim Hartford says, I shouldn't. Well, I have to say, since writing the book, I have stopped asking my children to clear up their room. And the reason is, the reason is, I read an amazing study that had been conducted by two British psychologists, Mae'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny hyn, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny hynny, a fwybod. Mae'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r pryddu cymryddiad o'r pryddu cymryddiad. Mae'n ffwrdd o'r pryddu cymryddiad,
ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad o'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad,
ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith I'm ever a boss, nobody should make me a boss, by the way. If I'm ever a boss, I will never impose a clean desk policy. And number two, me and my wife, we kind of are the boss in our house. And I no longer ask my children to tidy their rooms. And you know what? We don't argue about it as much. And the rooms are kind of as messy as they ever were.
It hasn't made any difference to the physical state of the rooms. It's just a little bit more peace. All right, so that's a perfect segue to what I want to talk about next, because I actually want to talk about office space and how we organize office spaces. And in fact, I have a clip from the cult classic movie office space, which I'm going to play for you. Hi, Milton. What's happening?
I'm going to have to ask you to go ahead and move your desk again. So, if you could go ahead and get it as far back against that wall as possible, that would be great. No, no, because that way we'll have some room for some of these boxes and things we need to put in here. No room. And, oh, there it is. What? Here, let me just go ahead and get that front.
Great. So if you could just get to that as soon as possible, that would be terrific. Okay. Thanks a bunch, Milton. Bye. Okay. I can sit and building on fire.
I take a tim that you are not a fan of fascist office managers. You do also tell the story in the book about Steve Jobs at Pixar and some of the ideas he had about how to organize office space to make people more collaborative and some of the ways that might have backed by. Yeah, the Pixar story I think is fascinating. So Steve Jobs, majority shareholder at Pixar, had a big hand in designing the Pixar building. And one of his big ideas is we are going to make all the bathrooms in this building in the middle of the building. We're just going to have two big restrooms, a pair of restrooms in the heart of the building. ymdwch i'n gweithio'r gweithio, mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'ael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o I know this sounds like a great idea on paper, Mr Jobs, but I need to go to the restroom three times an hour. And you've just made the restroom ten minutes away from my desk, do the maths, and it's not going to work. And Steve Jobs did an amazing thing. He backed down. He said, OK, I'm wrong. I will find another way to create serendipitous interactions, and you can, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy,bod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwy people feel they have control over. It looks like a total mess. In other words, it looks like your children's rooms.
Yeah, maybe slightly more creative than my children's rooms, but my children aspire towards the whole Disney castle thing. Tim Halford comes from Britain. We're having this chat in the United States. In both countries, there have been enormous political upheavals recently. When we come back, I'm going to ask Tim about messiness in public life and in democracy.
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. With Brexit and the election of Donald Trump Tim, we've had populous revolutions on both sides of the Atlantic that reject the advice of scientists and economists, experts in general. Democracy, of course, is famously messy. Could you remind people why it's such a good thing? Mae'n gweithio'r ysgwch yn y fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwy How is this going to make me stronger? How is this going to make my society stronger? What are the solutions that are going to come out of disappointment? Donald Trump ran a campaign that many people thought was extremely disordered.
He didn't listen to the experts. He went off script all the time. He said things that people said would be sure to make him lose. Now, your book came out only a few weeks ago, but clearly, he must have read an early draft. yw'n gweithio'r gweithio yn gweithio. Mae'r gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweith ymwch i'n gweithio yn gweithio. Iw'n gweithio yn ymwch i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio. I'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i o'r ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddododd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddoddodd yn ddod i'n gweithio'r yw'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio' and Noble are more confused than we are. And as long as Bonson Noble are more confused than we are, we're doing okay. He was very, very clear about this and it has proved very effective. I want to talk about another example of messiness in public life. And I want you to watch this video which describes a very famous speech.
And I want to ask the question right after it. We can never be satisfied as long as our children are stripped of their selfhood and robbed of their dignity by sign stating for whites own name. We cannot be satisfied as long as a Negro in Mississippi cannot go, and a Negro in New York believes he has nothing for which to go. Yeah. So as you can see from that speech, Tim, Martin Luther King is reading from a script.
And he has some nice line there, but it's a writerly line. But at a certain point in this speech, he decides to leave the script behind and turn his eyes to the audience and here's what we see after that. I still have a dream. It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. I have a dream that one day this nation will rise up, live out the true meaning of its creed. We hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men are created. Talk about this for a second, because you talk about this speech in the book and you talk about this moment when King left his notes behind and essentially stepped off the ledge of what he knew and what he was certain about and just rode the wave of what the crowd was telling him and what he was feeling. He had prepared that speech meticulously the night before and it's then at very late. He was operating on a number of constraints. It was quite a tight time schedule. The eyes of the world were on him, he knew that. There were also various political a'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r Now let us go back to our communities as members for the Society for Creative Disatisfaction. He doesn't say it. He says instead, go back to Alabama.
Go back to Alabama, go back to South Carolina, go back to Georgia, go back to Louisiana, go back to the slums and get holes in our northern cities. And there's another pause, and the people behind him on the stage know he's not on the script anymore. And Mahalia Jackson, great gospel singer, yells out to him because she's heard him talking in church about this dream. She yells out, tell him about the dream Martin.
And then he starts to improvise. And that is when he touches the crowd. I want to wrap by asking you a few personal questions. I understand that after writing this book, every time you find yourself in a mess and you turn to your wife for comfort, she now reminds you that being in a mess is a good thing. Yeah.
Actually, just two days ago, Shankar, I was trying to check into a hotel, a Dublin airport. Ym gydwch, ac mae'n gydwch yn ffordd o'r ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o fforddd o ffordd o fforddd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o that I would be able to get. And when I showed up at the airport hotel, they didn't have my reservation. And they were full. So no, we're just leaving. And as I toured Dublin in a taxi looking for hotels that were open, I could just hear my wife's voice in my head saying, this is making you smarter Tim. This is what you say.
This is making you more creative. So I've really sort of created a rod to beat myself with. But I think it's important. Mae'n gwaithio'r rhodd i'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio.
Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaith ymwch, yn ymwch, yn ymwch, yn ymwch, yn y, a'r hynny, a'r hynny, a'r hynweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem,
mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Thank you for joining me today. Thanks, Shrek. APPLAUSE Hidden Brain is produced by Maggie Penman, Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins, Parth Shah, and Renee Clar. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
Our unsung hero this week is an institution. We want to thank the NPR Foundation Board of Trustees, many of whom joined us for this taping with Tim Harford. They played a vital role in getting hidden brain off the ground, not just financial support, but guidance and emotional support as well. I'm so grateful. Next week we'll continue our U2.0 series with an episode about how to achieve your dreams.
Really. I'm Shankar Vidantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.